các bạn nghe rõ
ở Hà Nội đang
tôi đang chỉnh lại cho cho cái mic đỡ đỡ
nhạy hơn
Hà Nội đang mưa bão nên thành ra nếu mà
để mở nhảy hết cỡ như mọi khi thì mình
cũng sẽ nghe tiếng kiểu tiếng mưa ở đằng
sau lưng tôi
nay thì như mình nói hôm nay sẽ vẫn sẽ
làm một buổi biểu
tâm sự hỗ trợ các nhóm nếu các nhóm nào
muốn mình chữa
gì thì bình luận nhé
Còn không thì mình sẽ tiếp tục chữa cái
phun callender và hôm trước thì hôm
trước thì Lỡ không chừng cả một buổi
không kịp tâm sự gì cả Hôm nay mình xin
phép mình tâm sự buồn một tí đúng không
ạ
bảy này mình sẽ bảo vệ thử lần nữa cho
những nhóm mà muốn và
thứ ba tuần sau đi thứ ba tuần sau cũng
có thể bảo vệ thử đấy hai buổi Nếu mà
Thứ bảy này các bạn chưa bảo về thử được
thì thứ ba tuần sau các bạn nên bảo vệ
thử nói chung là đấy sẽ là những bảo vệ
thử cuối cùng
trước khi bảo vệ thật còn bảo vệ thật
thì sẽ là như mình nói thì có thể sẽ là
mùng 10 mùng 10 tháng 9 sẽ bảo vệ thật
và từ mùng 1 đến mùng 10 lúc mà các bạn
phải xong hết code rồi các bạn chỉ ngồi
làm tài liệu thôi tài liệu thì mình sẽ
những cái buổi hôm đấy là mình sẽ ngồi
hướng dẫn lại các bạn về tài liệu và
nhóm nào cần chữa tài liệu thì mình sẽ
mình sẽ kiểu chữa qua cho các nhóm đấy
để làm ví dụ bởi vì tài liệu đồ ăn 2 thì
sẽ có rất nhiều tính năng hơn đoán 1 và
các bạn cần phải khoe các bạn cần lưu ý
thì cách viết tài liệu nó sẽ kiểu Tuy là
tương tự thôi nhưng mà nhưng mà mình sẽ
phải chọn lọc hơn cách viết tài liệu
mình và đồ ăn 2 thì hãy nên nhớ vẫn là
sẽ có người
ngồi trong ngồi trong ban phản biện
không phải là mũi mình mình nữa nên là
mọi thứ Nên chuẩn chỉ đúng không ạ tôi
tôi cũng đặt hi vọng ở mấy ông mấy ông
bây giờ cứ cho là niềm tự hào của tôi
xong rồi cậu không bảo vệ thì
bảo vệ cho cả kiểu chất lượng chất lượng
dạy của tôi Tuy là tôi nói thế nó vẫn bị
đúng là nó nghe là áp lực thật và
Tôi đang muốn nói đó là mấy ông không
các bạn Mấy ông không phải là
kiểu dạng nhưng mà áp lực ở đây và áp
lực để cho mấy ông đôi khi áp lực phải
tạo nên kim cương đúng không ạ và áp lực
ở đây không phải khiến cho mấy ông nản
bỏ mà là áp lực ở đây là là để trong mấy
ông sẽ phải nghiêm túc trong ngày hôm
đấy rất là nghiêm túc về sẽ có người
khác giống như kiểu đi phỏng vấn bình
thường thôi nếu mà hôm đấy mà Mấy ông
bảo vệ thành công thì mấy cái Người đấy
Tôi sẽ mời cả HR nữa xem không phải ngồi
trong ban phản biện Thôi thì những bạn
những HR đấy mà thấy mấy ông ồn Làm mấy
ông được tuyển thẳng luôn ngang bằng
việc là ông đã qua được phỏng vấn nên là
hôm đấy mấy ông phải tự mình tỏa sáng
chứ tôi không giúp được gì cả hiểu chứ
nếu hiểu vấn đề không thế nên là mấy ông
sẽ phải rất là nghiêm túc và cũng như là
kiểu rất là chuyên nghiệp các thứ thứ
chuẩn bị hết toàn bộ tất cả tài liệu
phải chuẩn tài liệu thứ mà cho người
khác xem phải chuẩn đúng không ạ và tính
năng thì thực ra là như tôi đã nói là
thực ra không cần phải một cái phần mềm
có đầy đủ tính năng hoàn thiện gì gì cả
Quan trọng là mình có mình hiểu được
người dùng và nếu mà giả sử đưa những
câu hỏi tình huống là giả sử rằng nếu
muốn làm tính năng này hay là em đã cân
nhắc làm thêm tính năng cái gì gì đó để
tiện hơn chưa các bạn trả lời được thì
các bạn vẫn được tính ở ghi điểm rồi
chẳng qua là thời gian có hạn nên là các
bạn chưa có thời gian để làm cái mấy cái
thôi Nên là Nên là các bạn cũng cũng
không không phải sợ gì cả Không phải sợ
rồi Kiểu phần mềm mình có thể chưa xịn
bằng phần mềm những cái ông vừa mới demo
vừa nãy hoặc là chỉ đơn giản
bạn chính bản thân bạn nghĩ ở phần mềm
bạn vẫn chưa đủ tầm trăm triệu giả sử
thế Nhưng mà thực sự thì nó vẫn là xịn
Bởi vì các bạn đã tốn thời gian công sức
cho nó Và nó xịn hơn đoán một các bạn
cho dân nhiều đúng không ạ Các bạn hiểu
được các bạn đã làm gì và các bạn chứng
chỉ cần chứng minh được là các bạn làm
được việc là bao nhiêu thế thôi Đấy là
cái cái
tôi tự tin là như thế cái tôi thường hay
tự tin thế đó là thứ nhất là tôi không
bao giờ so sánh mình với bản thân à với
bất kỳ ai khác tôi không bảo phần mềm
được ngon hơn tất cả phần mềm khác mà
tôi tự tin là tôi biết được tôi đang làm
gì và tôi tự tin là kiểu sau sau kiểu
một khoảng thời gian đế tôi đã kiểu làm
được một cái gì đó rất là gọi là nó đưa
vào hoạt động nó vẫn sử dụng được đấy
Kiểu như thế thế nên là mình phải mình
phải tự tin những cái điều mình đã làm
và Mình thuyết phục được người khác là
nó chạy được đúng không ạ
Đi phỏng vấn bản chất là không phải là
bán sản phẩm của ông mà thực ra ông đang
bán chính ông cho người khác ông đang
kiểu
ông đang kiểu dạng rao bán chính ông cái
sản phẩm chỉ là cái thứ để mà người ta
nhìn qua Ừ đánh giá được phần nào con
người ông thôi Nên là ông phải rất là tự
tin tôi thì thấy nói chung là thấy các
bạn là khi bảo vệ thử các bạn cũng tự
tin lắm các bạn vừa giao diện đẹp hơn
tôi đấy tôi mà hồi mà tôi làm đồ ăn 2 mà
gặp mấy ông ấy sẽ là tôi cũng rẻ lắm
nhưng mà
nhưng mà Mấy ông vẫn phải chuẩn bị trước
các thứ thử Tôi vẫn đang tôi đã nhắc nhở
Cái này từ lâu rồi mà đúng không Nói
chung là hàng ngày hàng ngày giống như
là Mưa dầm thấm lâu hàng ngày hàng ngày
tôi nói mấy ông điều này nên là tôi hi
vọng là mấy ông sẽ chuẩn bị tâm lý ít
nhất là chuẩn bị tâm lý ổn chuẩn bị để
mà Đấy ra bán bản thân
cái gì xem đã cái này cần phải đăng nhập
bỏ qua À hôm trước
hôm trước thì công ty tôi thực ra là từ
đầu năm đến giờ ở công ty tôi bị dính
vài vụ mà thực ra nó có cả liên quan đến
chính tôi nữa Nó hơi bị nhạy cảm một tí
nó Nó là kiểu
nói với ông đó là kiểu liên quan một cái
dấu gì đó Bởi vì những cái lúc mà mình
mình chủ quan mình kiểu dạng là nghĩa là
đơn giản thành ra mình không cẩn thận
những cái lúc đấy và chính Những lúc
những cái lỗi ngớ ngẩn đấy nó lại gây
tác động rất là lớn và nguy hiểm đấy thì
lần gần nhất công ty tôi bị một ông
hacker ông ấy phá Tôi nghĩ là người Việt
bởi vì chạy VPN
màu đen sang Mỹ và lẫn cả là chạy vào
buổi trưa tầm trưa chiều tôi nghĩ là
người Việt thì lại người Việt cao
ông ấy muốn hack Apple Jackson đương
nhiên là không thể bởi vì nó nó có cái
kiểu là Bin Tức là tất cả kiểu như này
này
ai đi
bằng
1 2 3 xử thể
nhà chẳng hạn đúng không
câu truy vấn này nó sẽ tự sinh ra tự
sinh ra hộ mình và lấy đúng không ạ
này để xem có truy vấn thì mấy ông sẽ
thấy toàn bộ nó biến thành hỏi chấm và
nó sẽ truyền 1234 với thứ tự lần lượt
cái hỏi chấm này Đây là theo kiểu bay
đinh và nó khái niệm nữa là prepare
Jackson để Nếu giả sử Hồi trước Tôi từng
chỉ mấy ông về cái vụ SQL Jackson Giả sử
là mấy ông có thể là đóng cái ngoặc này
cho nó luôn Chạy chẳng hạn để tôi thử
nhé
Tôi sẽ nối chỗ ở đây à đóng cái này này
một bằng một này sau đó Thì Biến toàn bộ
đằng sau thành bình luận chẳng hạn
như này
Đấy Bây giờ tôi chạy thử
ghép để mấy ông xem thật lấy được lại
nha
không lấy được bê đê này
phải chạy chạy mấy ông xem thử được nha
đúng chứ tiếp theo hay toàn bộ Cái này
ở trong này đúng không
đóng o1 = 1 cái này biến đoạn đằng sau
Chú thích này
lỗi ở đây nữa
một con số gì đó chạy thử này
à không đổi cái này thành như này đi Cái
này được đúng không Bây giờ sẽ sửa lại
cái này bằng 1 này đổi cái này như này
đúng chứ
lái thử xem Đấy được nha
Vợ không lấy được đúng không Nhưng nếu
mà DD như này nó sẽ ra như này đúng chứ
đúng cái mà vừa nãy tôi làm thôi
đấy mấy ông sẽ thấy là
nếu mà giả sử mình truyền đúng cái hệt
vào trong cái kiểu cái param thì nó lại
quen juston biến cái này thành cái dấu
có ký tự đặc biệt nó có chức năng đặc
biệt là Biến toàn bộ đằng sau thành chồi
đích và nó sẽ kiểu nó sẽ kiểu ra là toàn
bộ nhưng mà không
lauelel Nó đã kiểu nó đã nó dùng Bin để
khắc phục được vụ này Ok cái việc bay
link này nó rất là ổn cho đến khi cho
đến khi gần đây tôi bị mất bức này tôi
bảo anh
Anh Tuấn Đăng bởi vì quả bấc này khiến
cho mình mất cũng bị Hơi bị mất niềm tin
vào cái Facebook này lắm tôi không tí
chắc là tôi sẽ thử tải larel 9 để xem nó
có bị dính hay không Bởi vì như ông ấy
bảo là là 8 bây giờ là nó không ngừng
không hỗ trợ cái phiên bản laoseo 8
thành ra là nếu mà có bấc liên quan 8
thì nó sẽ không sửa nhưng mà Cái Bấc này
khiến nó công ty tôi hôm đấy cũng lỗ
cũng bị ảnh hưởng về uy tín nữa quan
trọng ảnh hưởng uy tín đây nó sẽ có tình
huống như này xảy ra nó rất buồn cười
cho mấy ông xem
ông muốn
miền Nam nhé
theo cái thứ tự mà tôi muốn sắp xếp giả
sử như này giả sử như này tôi muốn ABC
này Long này
tôi muốn lấy ra tên nhưng mà theo thứ tự
này thì làm như nào không phải thiện thì
nó sẽ có cái này rất là hay để cho mấy
ông biết nó order by sau đó thì
nam chẳng hạn như này sau đó thì bản
chất mấy ông thấy nó là chuỗi đó nó đã
gợi ý cho tôi cái này nó chuỗi nên là
tôi sẽ ghép nó lại theo kiểu như này cho
mấy ông xem DD rồi nha Không xem thử có
truy vấn của tôi nó sẽ như thế
name sau đó truyền ABC Long 1 2 3 vào Và
đây là chuỗi thì sẽ nối nhau bởi kiểu
như này đấy được không ạ đó rồi tôi thử
chạy chạy thử cái câu này câu này nhá
ghét để lấy ra nha
tôi mở tab mới cho mấy ông dễ hình dung
đi
đêm thôi
Long rồi đến A B C sau đó toàn bộ những
tên còn lại đúng chứ đúng không tác dụng
của cái order by xong rồi thêm tên cột
đấy rất là hay
Cái này tác dụng được cho cả cột
kiểu dữ liệu là kiểu số nữa nhé chứ
không phải là mỗi kiểu chuỗi như thế này
chữ kiểu như này đâu đấy các bạn Để ý kỹ
nhé Tại sao lại có 1 2 3 lên đầu xong
rồi mới đến Long rồi đến A B C bởi vì
theo như thứ tự này thì thằng thằng dsc
tất cả điểm cao nhất thì thành ra thằng
này thằng điểm cao nhất hai điểm cao nhỉ
Hai điểm K3 Đúng chứ Đúng chứ nhớ nhớ
cái thứ tự này nhé
bây giờ bởi vì ở hôm đấy tôi bảo rồi Nếu
mà truyền thẳng cái ID truyền lên như
thế này đúng không ạ Và nối thẳng vào
chuỗi như thế này mấy ông thấy là cái
bay Đinh của thằng này nó đang là không
có trống tức là tôi chuyển thẳng vào
trong câu SQL nên là hôm đấy thằng
hacker nó kêu nó lợi dụng cái cái này nó
truyền thêm những cái ID rồi đấy nó
truyền swens thế không được Nên hôm đấy
tôi làm là tôi
kiểu truyền Nó theo kiểu là hỏi chấm
kiểu như này sau đó thì
rất là thông minh là theo kiểu là
rất là thông minh là nó tự động hiểu
được là đây là mình đang truyền vào mạng
và hỏi chấm này sẽ thay bằng ABC lòng
123 truyền ở trong này Ok chưa
sao quan trọng cái đáp án khi mà trả về
thì sao
bên này 1 2 3 Long a b c bên này ABC
Long
nhưng 1 2 3 cuối đúng không ạ Tại sao
như thế Tại sao
đúng chứ
4 cái đi
Tôi dùng cái truyền
Giả sử tôi chuyển khẩu nối chuỗi thẳng
vào thì 123 lên trên cùng sau đó đến
Long rồi đến ABC Đúng chưa Đúng không
Nhưng mà nếu Nhưng mà nếu mà giả sử tôi
kiểu dùng bai Đinh của thằng Ariel đấy
mấy ông thấy là nó sẽ truyền cả ba cái
vào vào trong thằng này và nối chuỗi với
nhau
đấy thì nó lại ABC long đúng đúng theo
thứ tự mình truyền vào nó còn hay hơn
thằng này Thái bị ngược mấy ông thấy ABC
xuống cuối rồi đến Long rồi đến 123
Nhưng mà riêng với số thì nó đẩy xuống
cuối như này cơ đấy nó là ưu tiên chữ
lên trên tôi không hiểu nó sinh ra câu
truy vấn kiểu gì ông trời Mày cho dù là
rõ ràng là hai mấy thằng này nó vẫn nối
vào đây và những thằng này thì nó không
biết được không biết có chị Vân nó ra
Kiểu gì để nó biến thành tình trạng kiểu
như
đấy nhưng mà chính vì tôi sửa đang từ
kiểu do thuần tôi sửa thành kiểu dạng
bai Đinh Tôi nghĩ rằng là tôi nghĩ rằng
là cái kết quả của mình trả về nó không
thay đổi nhưng mà Mấy ông thấy nó thay
đổi hoàn toàn đúng không ạ thứ nhất là
cái sắp xếp nó bảo đúng chứ ABC Long 1 2
3 Còn đây là ABC Long ABC lại lên trước
cả lòng như thế này đúng không ạ thứ hai
là với số thì nó đầy hẳn xuống cuối luôn
như này tôi không hiểu nó sinh ra câu
truy vấn kiểu gì thành ra như này đấy
nên là
tôi tôi chưa cài laser 9 để mà để mà
test lại xem vụ này còn bị không còn nếu
mà vụ này bị thì nó là bất khá là khá là
cũng khá là to đấy bởi vì kiểu nó sai về
mặt lúc đầu người dùng người dùng nghĩ
rằng là nó sẽ kiểu nó sẽ ra kết quả về
bản chất là cái bay đi nó không được
phép làm tác động thay đổi một cái gì cả
về dữ liệu đúng không ạ Nó sẽ hiểu là
truyền lại kiểu như này thôi mấy ông
hiểu tôi không đấy còn việc chuyền Sai
như này thì tôi thấy không Không ổn
đang nói gì nhỉ
chạy được hay không nó vẫn chạy được mấy
ông thấy chạy được nó không hề báo lỗi
gì cả thứ hai là tôi hôm đấy Tôi không
lấy dùng ghép mà tôi lại dùng first để
lấy ra thằng đầu tiên và tôi thấy là tôi
thay đổi thứ tự hai thằng này thì nó vẫn
chạy vẫn lấy là thằng đầu tiên vẫn bình
thường đấy và thứ ba là tôi test ở đây
là tôi lỡ không tép mọi trường hợp hôm
đấy là tôi test mỗi chuỗi tôi không hề
test số nên là thành ra là nó có vấn đề
như này Đấy nó oáy ăn vãi chưởng mấy ông
mấy ông thấy đấy đúng ạ Không hiểu với
trường trường hợp mà số như này thì nó
đã biến thành kiểu gì để ra được kết quả
như kia đúng không ạ chuỗi để hết lên
trên cùng vào số để hết sủng cuối Không
hiểu luôn đấy Nói chung là Chính vì
không hiểu được code của nó đã làm cái
gì thành ra là hôm đấy Nói chung là hôm
đấy kết quả ở trên trang web tôi bị sai
tính toán sai nó ra số liệu sai mà nên
tiêu đề hôm nay ông mấy ông thích tâm sự
thì tâm sự còn không thì tôi xin phép
Chữa nốt bài hôm trước lại tiếp tục ngồi
mò bài hôm trước ngày hôm trước là mình
đang làm à
Mình đang làm demo về cái
rồi việc là thêm mới một cái gì đó kiểu
dạng như này
Nếu giả sử vào như này
đi mình sẽ biết là tại sao sai
email trùng lặp lại và lỗi ok ok
đi làm thực tế là ở công ty tôi có mỗi
một anh dùng
và nó không phải là một tiêu chuẩn của
thằng labell nên thực ra tôi không biết
là dạy mấy ông sẽ như nào với mỗi người
cái đấy nó ở Định nghĩa khác nhau nhưng
mà Ừ chắc tôi sẽ bây giờ tôi sẽ Note lại
để tôi tìm hiểu theo ý theo ý hiểu của
tôi rồi tôi sẽ Hôm nào tôi sẽ chỉ mấy
ông nhé
ejs
không À đúng rồi
ông xem nhé
Để xem một thằng có chứa nhiều và một là
thằng đấy chính nhiều đúng không
có
đây
trừu tượng trừu tượng
này
lại là lấy từ từ cái thằng trung gian
hoặc từ language nó thể gọi đến ngược
lại cũng được
nhưng đại khái thì cách viết nó sẽ như
thế này nói chung à Một khi các bạn quen
cách viết của và hình dung được cách làm
đặc biệt các bạn nếu mà các bạn giả sử
không hiểu đi nữa Các bạn cứ gọi đến
hàng ngày xong rồi thử DD câu truy vấn
ra thì các bạn sẽ nắm rõ được thôi mà
Nếu giả sử các bạn không biết ddt
thì tôi đã từng dạy mấy ông về Display
lót này ra giáo xứ thế hoặc là các bạn
dùng tele Scope hoặc là dùng
Block walk Hoặc là đi mất 3 để các bạn
lấy được câu truy vấn Vân được mà
đang đến Ngô Tôi đang đi search vào
trong bảng user nên thành ra là tên này
trùng rồi nên là báo lỗi tên khác là
được đó ok rồi nên thông báo một cái ở
đây nữa đúng không ạ gì nhỉ Bây giờ thì
bây giờ giả sử là khi tôi muốn bấm vào
để sửa một cái gì đó tôi sẽ thử Quay lại
cái đầu hôm trước nhé
bấm
mình lấy được
cái gì Hai Thù này chấm event để lấy hết
được những cái
khác
chấm Ý Vân trong Vân nó sẽ có
hoặc là
ở đây thay thổ thay thổ
muốn lấy thời gian của nó thì tôi sẽ goe
thời gian để mà tôi để mà tôi
bởi vì cái thằng này này mình truyền về
nó không có ai đi nên là mình sẽ không
sửa theo ID được mình sẽ sửa theo thời
gian
bản chất là thời gian bây giờ nó cũng
cũng
thời gian có chung không nhỉ thời gian
trong trường hợp này đang đang được phép
trùm Nhưng giả sử Nếu nó không được
trùng thì mình sẽ quen thời gian nó sẽ
chuẩn
ID kiểu gì nhỉ
à sẽ khi trả về các bạn trả về thêm ai
đi cho chắc nhé để ở mình nghĩa là khi
trả về thêm cái ID để cho
cậu nó ôi
vẫn chỉ đang mang tính chất demo nhé gà
các bạn sẽ phải khi load vào như này các
bạn đẩy lên ấy đẩy lên thì các bạn sẽ
phải các bạn Thấy có cái start
nó luôn chuyển lên cái start với em như
thế này luôn lấy cái status này chuyển
lên rồi các bạn sẽ quen
trong cái đấy để nó kiểu không phải ghét
thì lấy hết như này
nó sẽ như này
có status này các bạn sẽ quen đúng cái
start và en thì thôi
quay bít Win này
start and
ghét lấy hết ra này sau đó thì mình sẽ
Ford ở đây
user này mình sẽ
mình sẽ còn trỏ đến hàng ngày để mình
ghi ghi thêm vào dữ liệu vào trong thằng
user mình sẽ có user
sẽ bằng user cho đến ID xong rồi nối
cách nhau rồi dấu như thế này và đây là
lên như này chẳng hạn
sẽ là user cho đến cái tật Ất chẳng hạn
thế tôi đang demo nha
format của nó là format như nào đã
Hình như là
như là không cần nó tự động format mấy
ông thấy là không cần nó vẫn tự động
hiểu
cứ thử Xóa đi đã
em
name
Nó có lỗi không
thường là nếu mà như thế thì tôi sẽ chọn
là tôi sẽ tạo ra một cái mảng mới như
này thì hợp lý hơn này tôi mảng mới tôi
sẽ có một cái object
bằng như này
sẽ là
cả đoạn này đi
luôn Mình trả về thôi
vẫn ra đúng không cái này là ID của nó
kèm theo đằng sau này
sang bên này ra ok hợp lý đấy thì khi
mình bấm vào đây này thì mình có lấy
thêm cái event có cái title là là cái
số này này
mình sẽ cắt từ số này mình lấy được ID
của cái thằng mà mình đang sửa nó sẽ như
này mình sẽ
là
mình sẽ ít nó để xem
nó sẽ là như thế nào
nó sẽ là
cái mô đồ này tôi thường hay dùng Chính
cái mô đồ 9 cái model này nếu mà truyền
thêm ID thì mình sẽ hiểu là sửa
còn nếu mà không thì mình sẽ hiểu là là
thêm đấy tôi thích là như thế nên là tôi
đang nghĩ tôi sẽ tận dụng nó ở ngay đây
thì ở đây sẽ là
muốn là truyền thêm cái ID ở đây
thường Thái thù Mình nên có cái vụ đấy
booking ID
lấy cái
sẽ bằng
đúng không ạ
dấu gạch
chuỗi bởi dấu gạch dưới sau đó lấy cái
lấy cái thằng à Lấy thằng trước lấy hàng
số 0 như này tôi thử con Solar trong log
cái ID mấy ông xem
à quên quên
đúng không Sau đó tôi sẽ truyền cái đi
thằng này vào là xong
tem l Đúng rồi chấm text hơn
tôi sẽ đương nhiên là tôi muốn cái model
này hiển thị lên rồi đúng không ạ Mua đồ
booking hiển thị lên sâu lên đúng không
ạ nhưng ngoài ra thì mình sẽ có một cái
input ẩn ở đây nữa là ID booking sẽ là
dạng đây ID booking
trùng à xem
booking đi
cho phân biệt cái là
spam ID booking nhé một cái này sẽ là
Zalo nó thẳng như này luôn này bằng id
này
Đấy là sửa tôi không để nó hai lần tôi
cứ tạm xóa cho mấy ông xem nhé
bấm này đó thấy số hiển thị lên không
Ok chưa ngon chưa Chị chưa
hết ở đây nên đổi thành pút nhưng mà tôi
nghĩ là để mấy thớt là post cũng được
không sao cả mình chuyển thẳng vào một
cái một cái vẫn là Store nếu thế là tên
đây tôi cũng phải sửa lại luôn Nó là
update
update booking đi
booking
store booking request ở cái hàng tên nhẹ
được rồi ngày bao nhiêu bảo vệ đồ án
anh có nói đấy Đó là thứ bảy này sẽ bảo
vệ thử còn nếu mà lịch chốt thì có thể
là
tháng sau sẽ là mùng 10 nếu mà tôi xem
tôi đương nhiệm phụt thuốc xem là mấy
ông
đang làm như thế nào đã
[âm nhạc]
để cái đoạn này
Nhưng mà khi bình tĩnh khi mà bấm vào để
mà hiển thị ra cái như này thì thường là
tôi sẽ làm như này tôi sẽ cậu
gọi Ajax để mà lấy dữ liệu về để mà in
ra cái duration ở đây
trước khi hiển thị ra được cái môđun sau
này nó sẽ là mình mình sẽ Cần lấy lại
thông tin của cái mà mình bấm vào mày
không hiểu không ạ
nên là tôi sẽ có ở đây đây là ghét user
cái này bạn sẽ phải UR Crafting thôi tôi
lỡ đặt thế thôi này
hoặc là mấy ông có thể đặt tên nó là sâu
mình sẽ truyền lên chính là truyền lên
gái đi này này mình sẽ truyền lên
chuyển router cả nhà nhé là mình sẽ bị
không lấy được cái router à không không
truyền được proton của thằng pp Nếu mà
ghi kiểu như này
nó hơi bị khó chịu một điểm như thế
mình sẽ thấy nó bị lỗi là router này bắt
buộc phải truyền một cái giá trị vào cho
nó đúng chứ nhưng mà do là mình không
thể can thiệp ra squip vào trong code pp
này được kể cả các bạn có hỏi chấm ở đây
nó không nó vẫn không nhận ra bị buồn
cười
nên cách làm ở đây thì ông
tôi không biết là hỏi không biết là hỏi
chấm ở đây có được không Để thử nhé
Và Chấm ở đây thì nó sẽ không báo cái
lỗi
không báo về lỗi này nữa
nhưng mà ý tôi là không biết chuyện này
đi kiểu vào nó được không
đi bằng kiểu như ID xem được nha
Thằng này mất rồi
thằng này nó là
số ít luôn đi
đi này
sẽ đơn hạn và tích phân
sẽ phải gọi request như bình thường thôi
user
web file
thật ắt để ra đuôi asun đấy
2to thì sẽ bằng
thì nó mới nhận để tôi một tí
sẽ ổn hơn ok
trả về dầu Nhưng mà giờ theo số
cầu dạng mà
nó sẽ kiểu trả về hai thay vì kiểu nó
kiểu ra số chẵn
đây tôi thử thử luôn nhé
Tôi thường là tắt bớt mấy cái này đi này
lấy những cái thứ mình cần luôn này
trả lại này
3,33 ok rồi mẹ đúng rồi
ông muốn tạo chết nữa thì làm đoạn này
nó dễ hơn
mình sẽ đổ dữ liệu in vào trong cái đuôi
chân
ở đây
đúng không ạ
Mình sẽ có là đuôi Trần
Thái thù sẽ là Thái thủ thế thôi
thấy nó đang bị lặp lại toàn bộ Cái này
thì khi mà sâu một cái gì đó ra như thế
thì toàn chính xác là mình sẽ phải
reset khi mình sẽ bắt sự kiện là khi mà
cái mua đồ này được kích hoạt thì mình
nên reset Model là chuẩn nhất
form này này
Đợi tí nhé
không cơ Hình như có đấy
không cho 1 đây sẽ là
đã không reset được
tôi rồi
Thế thì online cho nó hay thì ẩn đi
có vẻ reset được rồi nó mất đi thì tôi
sẽ chỉ cần đổi cái này thành chỗ rỗng
có gì có
cùng mất rất nhiều thời gian nhưng thôi
không sao đó thì mấy ông thấy là
tôi vừa làm đó là cái trò kiểu gì để mà
kiểu tận dụng cái mua đồ cái thứ thứ
bấm vào Thằng này nó sẽ ra chi tiết này
thử Quick xem có được cái trò này không
nhỉ
Bấm vào chỗ khác ra kiểu khác đúng không
ạ
Bây giờ mới là đến cái đoạn quan trọng
hơn là bây giờ mình sẽ kiểu mình sẽ cập
nhật nhưng mà bây giờ thêm cả ID nó sẽ
như nào có lúc có ID thì mình sẽ như thế
nào vào lúc không có đi mình sẽ xử lý
như nhau nhé
Thì ở đây
hôm trước thì mình làm thêm thì thêm vẫn
thêm được nhé Vẫn thêm bình thường được
thử cho mấy ông xem này
nào
mình sẽ có mấy ông thấy là khi mình sửa
như này sắp mít
không
phải vậy
này thì mình sẽ hiểu nó là update
đầu tiên là mình sẽ kiểm tra là nó có
tồn tại hay không đã ở ngay ở trong
vidate thì mình sẽ làm đó là mình sẽ
kiểm tra là đây ID
đây sẽ là
không phải luôn đây bồ mà là kiểu
ít xx kiểm tra nếu mà tồn tại thì mình
sẽ như thế nào
[âm nhạc]
tra hơi là được thì phải
kiểm tra là không cần nói kiểu dữ liệu
gì cả sẽ thường nghe luôn này sau đó thì
tồn tại như này
user flash
của ID
mình sẽ kiểm tra Nó tồn tại hay không
ở đây sẽ là
nhá mình sẽ có user như này bằng user
gọi hàm update à Tôi không biết có hàng
này cơ
mà sếp cơ
bằng là nối chuỗi của Jack
theo fail mấy ông kiểm tra bên này rồi
nhé mình sẽ chỉ cần pha như là được
chiều nay đi vào như này xong rồi lấy
được ai đi Để update Tôi không biết được
hàm này nếu mà chạy update như này nó có
gọi đến chữ câu
bên này
chuyển date than lên trên này
cập nhật truyền lên
đúng rồi khi cập nhật thì mình vẫn phải
lấy hết hạn
Ok nghĩa là khi mình ấn vào đây mình
thiếu cái vụ là hết hạn rồi
đi thành ra không hề biết được date mình
đang trống
không rõ được mình có lấy được cái than
khi mình bấm vào nó không ý tôi đang cầm
là như thế
Ajax gọi về rồi Kiểu gì mình chẳng có
lấy được hết
gọi đến cái thằng này
chuyển về là deadham
nhảy lên ngay ok đó mấy ông vừa thấy cốt
của tôi nó bao gồm cả việc là update và
sẽ theo kiểu như này Đây là một cách đây
là một cách để mà ông xử lý cho cậu
update are
tôi thường hay không biết dùng cách này
mà tôi sẽ dùng cách nào tôi thường hay
kiểu
lúc tôi sẽ thương hai cũng có file như
này nhé
ở đây sẽ
thế này để hiểu là thế mới này
sau đó thì gì vết thằng này Xuống đây là
Fill lấp đầy mạng như này sau đó đưa ra
user chạy đến Hàm set như này là xong
tôi thường hay thích kiểu cách này hơn
mấy ông xem nhé
không
đây thì tôi rồi
ơ mình ngồi cập nhật nãy giờ cập nhật
một thằng à
nhật một thằng Bảo sao
cập nhật
không sao
bấm vào đây này
chuyển lại đi lên là không hợp lệ Ok sẽ
luôn label ở đây vậy
cho phép truyền lên ID ở trống
vừa nãy mình cập nhật mấy thằng này lạ
thế
có vẻ sửa được này
về cách thêm sửa xong rồi dùng vài date
các thứ thử có thể gộp chung một cái mô
đồ
để xử lý đúng không ạ tổng hợp buổi hôm
nay nào
Nhiều vãi chưởng
lâu tôi không cập nhật trong đống này
Vào trong này toàn cái anh ta tính mà
đóng này request
cha buổi hôm nay mình tạm kết thúc đấy
nhé cũng thấy chẳng có câu hỏi gì cả
cái này đại khái tổng hợp lại thì hôm
nay sẽ là hồi ngồi chỉnh lại về sử dụng
mua đồ thực ra mua đồ không quan trọng
lắm Bởi vì recovery mới có mua đồ thôi
cùng một form có lúc thì mình sẽ chuyển
id lên để hiểu mình update còn còn không
thì mình sẽ hiểu là Insert mình sẽ xử lý
như nào mình có thể xử lý cùng chung một
request là như thế này Đấy cái cách Hôm
nay tôi xử lý cho bao gồm mỗi thế nhỉ
cách để làm việc luôn với kiểu
cái này ở Cacbon tức là lấy thư viện của
nó để mà có thể sử dụng kiểu dạng là
xử lý với thời gian các thứ thứ
như thế thôi
cũng loạn lắm
Thôi bỏ hôm nay đã kết thúc đấy Thôi
hẹn các bạn vào thứ bảy
anh là sinh viên năm mấy vậy Hay đang đi
làm rồi anh
chào bạn nhé